hey guys my name is Archana and welcome
to the next episode of a sterilization
mini-series okay so today we're going to
be talking about the actual details of
the format and we're going to go through
it bite by bite to is to ensure that
that we understand how it works and this
is just going to be like another one of
those planning situations where we're
going to have to just make sure that
everything we actually will put into
this format makes sense and and just
just so that we have an overview of how
it's structured so last time we we
basically did take a look at this
database thing right now inside the
database we brothers hair we've got this
object array and then we've also got a
bunch of fields inside the object right
and then a bunch of field definitions
from whatever inside there just to make
sure that we understand how fields work
and all that and then a footer at the
end so this is the this is the core
structure okay but how does it work like
actually so what's inside the header
what's inside the field definition all
that kind of stuff as well that's what
we're going to take a look at today so
step one the header what is inside our
header well a few things okay now we're
going to go through this byte by byte
essentially and if you guys see anything
that doesn't make sense to you or if you
see something and you're like hey
wouldn't it be better to do this then
please please leave a comment below I
will address them individually probably
I'm actually kind of bulk recording a
bunch of episodes in a row without
putting them out just because I am
trying my best to keep this series daily
right now which means that I'm going to
have to do a lot of forward planning
which is what I'm making I'm recording
like two or three episodes today so
because of that I won't really see your
comments until after I recorded the next
two or three videos but I will get to
them eventually and we might do a formal
like review of this series or whatever
with all your concerns but um basically
everything here should be pretty pretty
rock-solid so anyway we've got this head
up and then what's going to be inside
his head on so essentially the first
thing we're going to have is an
identification thing so we're going to
have two bytes so this entire system let
me just quickly because this format is
going to make more sense once I explain
what it's for this is for my
for the game programming series called
rain rain is the name of the game I
don't know why it's called brain it's
just called rain okay so this
multiplayer networking component
I have called rain cloud okay because
like you know cloud is like you know
it's on the cloud it's like a network
it's like cloud computing type of deal
right and then rain cloud also kind of
makes sense like kinda like a storm
cloud or any I think anyway I quite like
that I quite like that name so that's
kind of the name of this kind of
sterilisation format will be for rain
cloud essentially a rain cloud of course
is the library in charge of all the
networking for rain okay so that being
said we're going to have two bytes at
the start which are just basically going
to be R and C okay this is going to be
two bytes and these are going to be the
very first two bytes here the file okay
so when you read this you are like okay
this is an RC file I was on my lap right
you know that it's going to be it's
going to be our ization format okay
so again as I mentioned before this is
like kind of like a sanity check thing
and to make sure that we're actually to
basically identify what file this
actually is because we have no idea
otherwise right whether or not we
actually do perform a sanity check or we
just skip these bytes and we assume that
there is something is another matter of
discussion and whether or not it's also
necessary to send these bytes over the
appli met work again up for debate but I
personally think we should anyway I'm
not gonna keep writing bytes everywhere
so I'm just going to say out here that
this is going to be like the two bytes
right so this is this is like the
beginning this is like offset this is
address zero and then and we're going to
kind of go on here as we go so the first
few bites parsing done the next two
bytes are going to be the version okay
so this is going to be a short hence
it's two bytes long it's just going to
be a 2 byte or a 16 bit integer and it's
going to identify our version so yeah
we'll probably just start off with like
version 1 and then your version 2 3 4
etc right let me keep is pretty simple
it's also quite popular
by the way to have to kind of like like
two of these right so you might have
like two and two by it's like full bytes
turtle to describe the version or you
might even have eight bytes total four
plus four to describe the version and
you would have something called a min oh
sorry I'm like a min version essentially
which is the minor version and then in
like a matter I'm like a major version
right so like OpenGL uses this kind of
system so do many other things by the
way if Angele is just one example where
you might have something like if you are
talking about opengl 4.4 i've been
storing that as a decimal would be a bit
weird
you've got the major version which is
this one over here and then a minor
version which is this one over here okay
so that's something that you could do as
well if you wanted to this is not really
that necessary though so we're going to
just store two bytes here we're just
going which we're just going to describe
the version okay you probably could get
away with storing one byte
I love two bytes there just in case we
want to do like a major minor kind of
thing because in that case the first
byte could be the major version the
second black will be the minor version
something like that or the other out the
other way around as well I get up for
discussion because remember one byte can
store up to 255 from anywhere from 0 to
255 right that's the largest number it
can store 255 which is FF right which is
weigh it off for us but anyway we'll
actually talk about that as well because
Java doesn't actually have anything cold
like an online file
it's something got signed by its and
we'll deal with that later it's not
really a problem though that's a spoiler
but it's not really a problem anyway
the next thing we'll have is going to be
one byte and these are going to be our
flags okay so this is actually going to
be a bit field we're going to talk more
about bits and bytes in the next video
okay but this is essentially going to be
what's called a bit field now
essentially this flag is going to be a
collection of boolean's
normally if you were to write out of
bullying or something like that you'll
notice that bullying is actually 1 byte
the reason a bullying takes up 1 byte
which to you might make no sense right
now you would be correct assuming that
how does why does it take up one bite
surely a bullying is just one bit right
it's only got two states on or off right
true or false
why does it take up a whole bite the
reason it takes up a bite is because
that is actually the lowest size I guess
that we can actually address right in
memory you cannot address bit by bit in
memory okay that's not how Hardware
works so because of that we are left
with the minimum space or something if
you take up essentially being one byte
however you can encode your bullen's as
bits okay so essentially this Flags
thing is capable of storing eight
bullying's okay one for each bit okay in
that byte so that's what's gonna happen
I will show you exactly how that works
in future videos but that's the idea and
having something like that is called a
bit field so for example like the most
significant bit might indicate whether
or not this is compressed for example we
might put a one there the next one might
be like you know this is in like a
series the other one might be like which
I don't know encryption technology we're
using for example whether or not we're
using that might be one and then the
next one might be something else and you
can see that we end up like with
essentially like a bit field kind of
situation and then we can simply extract
each bed and be like if the bit is on
then you know that state is set to true
that's how kind of kind of how it works
but it's going to be our flag so this
will be like essentially we have we now
have eight flags whether or not we use
all of them is not really I don't know
we might not we might I really couldn't
imagine using more than two of them
right now but there will be things to
pop up cool so there's a reflects now
the next thing is going to be the name
so we are going to store the name of the
database because remember this is a
header for the database which is that
single file so let's talk about how we
can store names so names are basically
just a bunch of characters okay so we
might have something like as I said for
like we might call this something like
alpha I don't know I just made that up
on the spot this database might be
called alpha right alpha has five
characters in it the problem is that we
don't know that alpha has five
characters in it and really we've got
two options here basically the problem
is this once
once this gets encoded into the bite
thing we for example know right now that
the sixth bite on words right is going
to be the name because the first five
bites are these things right so we know
that bite number six starting from the
top here if this is by one will be the
beginning of name but how do we know
where name ends right because you might
be like well that's obviously when we
run out of characters but remember
characters are just numbers in binary
okay and we have no idea really when
this ends because it might go on for
another character or it might stop
somewhere short right we need to know
how big it is so we have two options for
that okay there are really two options
and in fact a lot of civilization
formats actually pick both just as like
a safety kind of proportion thing but
essentially we can either store the size
of the string beforehand so in this case
we would literally store like five for
example beforehand and then we have the
letters Al PHA and of course this means
that this the next five bytes are going
to be our string so we can extract the
next five bytes pop them into a string
and we're done again then we know that
whatever comes after that is already not
part of this string anymore
because we know that it's going to be 5
by 2 on okay that's one option
option number one right option number
two is to simply have a null termination
character at the end there so what that
means is that you have your string so we
don't have this byte at the front
usually it would be more than one byte
by the way cuz strings you know
typically might be longer than 255
characters if you've got like a long
description for something it might be
like I don't know 500 characters or
something for example so you would
typically have like a short here because
again that will an unsigned short will I
have 65,536 characters from 235 really
characters okay so you typically have
like I showed that instead of a instead
of a byte but you could have a buyer
today if you like in this case we've
just gone one byte which is five so we
know the string ends however we don't
have this size in this case we just have
the letters al P H a
then we have what's called an Ulta like
a termination character
okay and what this is is essentially a
backslash zero that's what the character
looks like it's a backslash and then a
zero now a backslash zero is really just
a zero okay so we have all about
characters here which are numbers such
as like I don't know what a is forty
something or something right we have all
these characters here and then at the
end of the string we have this zero okay
and that means the string is over and
this is actually how C++ and C store
char arrays or rather chalk like kind of
C's C strings really in memory right we
have we have this pointer to the
beginning of the like we have this
pointer to the first character and then
basically as far as you know we are
concerned this string continues on until
that a null termination character until
it reaches that termination character
which is life you like making your own
string class and you forget to include
this termination character you're gonna
run into problems because basically the
string will run on until it sees the
next zero in memory which is possibly a
while right so you might have issues
with that but the idea is that's that's
the second option we could have a male
termination capture we could also have
both of these things right so we've got
both a size and a termination character
we're probably going to just have a size
honestly because I feel like that might
be a bit better I personally prefer
having a size because it's kind of more
useful information I feel and then we
don't have to actually keep scouting
until we reach to zero we can
immediately say I want to scan these
bytes that's just a personal preference
you did performance wise or whatever
there's no difference and as I said a
lot of formats have both okay but I
wanted to mention that because it's
important to realize how strings for
example sort of memory okay so all that
aside we've got this stuff and then
we've got the name okay
so the name first we'll have the name
sighs okay so how many characters the
name takes up so this is going to be a
two byte as I said it's going to be a
short and this is going to be
essentially the name sighs okay or the
name count or something like that name
length really is what I should call it
so throughout this format I just want to
quickly mention here throughout this
format length
we'll essentially kind of refer to like
a count right whereas if you see the
word size anyway in the code it actually
means size in bytes okay
now you could use these interchangeably
with this thing because we're going to
be using standard non-white characters
which essentially means that we using
ASCII which essentially means that one
character is one byte no more or less
right we can't have we don't have two
black characters which is something like
utf-8 or other encodings might use in
fact I think you do affair uses it but
essentially we're not using white wide
chance which means that we have two
bytes for char we're using we're using
just normal one byte characters which
means that length and size and count
actually do mean the same thing but
anyway just something that's worth
mentioning okay and then of course we
have a variable length array of string
array of characters okay so we've got a
string and again that is a variable
length but worry not we know how long it
is because the previous two bytes
actually describe how long it is so we
know when we stop okay
and that's that whole string situation
okay so that's how we store strings and
that's how we will store the name of our
database so now that we've read the name
of the name of our database we at least
now know what it's called it's called
alpha is that important is it important
to have a name for our database no
absolutely not
in fact you would probably trim this if
you were setting in network packets
because it's a waste of space we do not
care what the database is called okay
the only reason we ever care about that
is for like debugging purposes and
whatnot okay there's no reason to have
that name in there because it is not
useful data at all okay and again you
can see that this for example takes up
five plus two by so it takes up seven
bytes of space that is just absolutely
worthless so this is something that we
might potentially cut from like the
runtime kind of network format but right
now we're just gonna keep it in there
because again it's great for debugging
and it's good to be able to have a name
for a database okay so next up we have
at this video I was expecting this video
to take like five minutes but like that
of Ciroc I'm always wrong about video
lengths anyway the next thing we're
going to have is two things we're going
to have an object count which will be a
2 byte thing all right so this is going
to be our object count
now remember arrays are also objects and
we'll get into that in a minute but
essentially to basically what this this
short will describe is how many objects
are in our database so for example we
might have like 7 objects or something
like that which means they expect 7
objects essentially ok and then that's
pretty much it for our database at the
we're going to have all of our meaty
kind of objects and arrays or whatnot in
between and then at the end we're going
to have the footer ok and then let's
talk about the footer real quick so the
foot is going to be mmm the foot is
going to be a 2 byte let me just put the
size out here a 2-byte the footer
essentially and it's going to be as I
said just for now it's going to be 2 by
it's 1 2 3 & 4
ok we'll talk about NDMS by the way in
our list this is like this isn't like a
big-endian kind of format here but we'll
we'll talk about endianness and whatnot
next time when we talk more about bits
and bytes but we will have like a foot
of this essentially 1 2 3 4 so just to
be like hey this is the end of the file
and everything is correct ok cool so
let's talk about our objects ok sorry
objects over here so what objects
contain well we could do something like
I mentioned with fields how I mentioned
that fields have something called a
field definition we could have an object
definition for our objects but I don't
think I'm going to do that just because
it's potentially not really required and
also I'll show you guys how to implement
something without a definition and with
a definition so I think that'll be
useful as well but I'm not going to have
an object definition I'm just going to
have the data straight off which is
basically the same as having it by the
way it's the same as having an object
definition kind of classes is the we're
not having the class so like the data
structure will still be the same we'll
talk about
well it's kind of hard to explain all of
this in a concise way but basically what
we've got is the first thing we see with
an object is a type we absolutely have
to have a type now this is not the type
of data inside the object okay because
remember the type of data inside the
object is going to be in the field kind
of subsection right this is the type of
object so this is going to be a 1 bytes
type here okay and really right now all
we care about a one of two options it's
either an object or it's an array it's
one of those two for now that's
absolutely it okay the reason we have to
know which one it is is because the next
few bytes are going to potentially have
extra things if it's an array okay so
I'll be checked or array if it's an
array we're going to go over here and
we'll talk about that in a second if
it's if it's an object going to go down
here so this is like almost like a flow
diagram now it's beautiful so there's
this object right what does it have next
well it's going to have a name which
means that we have a name length or yeah
so we've got our name length rotator and
then we have of course the name of the
object so this might be something like
entity or like entity a or something
like that right and then we're going to
have the fields so how the fields going
to be stored well we're going to have a
field count oh that's that's horrific
come on shadow and try harder here we're
going to have a field count which is
just the number of fields that are in
this object and then we're actually
going to have the fields so the fields
are going to go down here and this is
like another level of abstraction kind
of so the fields are going to work
pretty simply the fields are going to
have a field definition as I said a
definition which we're going to go out
here to and then the actual data
now the data in the field is just going
to be a variable kind of vitae ray okay
now this is a field right which means
that it can really store one or two
things it could store an object or it
could store primitive data that's it
right now
okay remember objects do have the
objects do have the capability to also
be an array so arrays and objects are
the same things right as in an array is
an object right but essentially we have
something like that now the definition
is removable is a bit more interesting
okay because the definition contains
everything that actually describes this
data hence it's called a definition
right so usually will have a 2-byte type
this honestly could be one by because I
don't think we're gonna have more than
255 different yeah this is gonna be a
one byte I originally have this is a two
pipe but it doesn't mean any sense we're
gonna have one byte type okay and then
we may have a two byte size now the
problem that I'm seeing with this is
that this is kind of redundant because
if we know the type of data we also know
the size of data okay however if it's
like an object we may not know the size
but we can step into the object and
figure out the size by looking at its
fields okay so this might be something
that you might want to do and we'll see
how we go but size is something that
remember a full primitive data you can
work that out from type for example if
the type says that we've got like an int
32 then we know that the size will be 4
right 4 bytes okay so we don't need to
work that out as in like we don't need
to store that as like an extra 2 bytes
of space because we can work that out
for the type so that's something to
think about okay
we also have the name length
okay and the name so this is the name of
the field and that's it so really what
we need is the type of the name okay now
we've also got this thing here that will
be stored at run time called an offset
okay and an offset is going to be
basically hey you've got a database
right we've got our database up the top
there this field starts at byte number
52 okay so if you want to read this
field open up the database but it's very
beginning and essentially browse the
fifty-second by now I don't know why I
wrote it like a 0x at the front of it
because that obviously makes that
hexadecimal which means it's not 52 but
pretend that I didn't write this because
I don't know why I did I'm just trying
to be able by T and all cool but
essentially that means that okay it's a
50 second part or whatever which means
that we can look up like array index 51
in our data byte array and that's the
beginning of this field okay the offset
and if we want to get the definition
well the definition tells us the offset
is obviously we know everything about it
that's how we can read the actual data
we may we may or we may not integrate
something like this because if we've
read the definition we might as well
read the data but you know just
something to think about okay cool so
there we go there's a field and there is
the data now however if the data is an
object we kind of go back up to up to
how can I draw this arrow well I'll just
draw it here that's a bad idea we
basically go up to here okay so we go
back up here and we say we say what is
is an object or isn't a right so we've
covered objects objects pretty simple
right they basically contain a name and
a bunch of fields which have definitions
which describe those fields that's it
very very simple stuff the array however
is just a little bit more complicated
because we just need to know essentially
what is it in the array okay and how
much of it there is so for the array we
have we have a type obviously because
we need to have a type because that that
needs to mirror this this is the type
that isn't both of these so I probably
don't need to write this again here but
just so you know the first bite of an
object or an array is this type because
it has to say I'm an object or I'm an
array okay after that we've got kind of
the same situation we've got a name
obviously so we've got name length and
we've got the name which is variable
length of course name and then what
we've got is essentially we've got the
type of data so this is usually
something you would keep in a field but
in write doesn't have fields because an
array is like one big field right so
it's very common for you to actually
have an array as a field which you can
have because fields can of course
contain objects as well as primitive
data mmm
so the name after the name we have
essentially the type which is two bytes
again you can work out the size from the
type so we don't really need to worry
about having this size okay and then we
just have the count which is also going
to be two parts so this is the count of
how many elements are actually in this
array okay
so again if we were sterilizing like an
array of integers as I said which were
the pixels of like a full HD monitor for
example that would be 2 million this
count would be 2 million now you may
have noticed already that this is the
problem because 2 million is not a
number we can store in to 2 million is
barely a number that we can store in an
integer
really no sorry that's 2 billion I meant
yeah it's not it's not a number we can
sort here because even if this was on
sign it would only be like 65,000 so 2
million is something that we need is
your fault which is why this count is
actually going to be an integer now that
does limit us to 2 billion I think
that's enough though like we're gonna
just say that that's enough so this
count is going to be 4 cool ok and then
after that we basically just have
variable length data
so variable length data how do we figure
out when it ends that's the big question
very very simply okay we just know that
the type will give us the size of each
element and we know how many there are
so if we have two million integers or
something and I know that the size of an
integer is 4 for example which it is at
least a 32-bit integer is is that size I
know that I have eight million bytes to
read okay so we read in eight million
bytes and then that's what we end and we
know that each every four bytes out of
those eight million bytes is a new
integer that we have to basically put
into that's how we can interpret the
data okay there we go done not that
difficult at all that's it that is our
entire format you can see how simple it
is it's really not that complicated okay
obviously the most complicated the
header is really simple the most
complicated thing we have is this entire
object hierarchy and how we can actually
read it but that's it
it's very simple it's really nothing to
be afraid of I'm going to walk you guys
step-by-step through everything so that
you understand everything so don't be
scared we're going to start implementing
this and we're actually gonna start
writing code tomorrow okay in a way what
we're going to do tomorrow is we're
actually going to take a look at binary
okay am I going to take a look at all of
the bit operations that we're actually
going to have to perform to manipulate
these bits and how to actually write out
these files and on how to actually
format our data in a way that we can
sterilize okay so basically it's going
to be like a bitwise operations kind of
tutorial on the next video okay the
reason I'm doing that is because I'm
sure that a lot of you don't really know
how to use these or have been avoiding
using them or have been waiting for me
to make a video about them because every
time I use a bitwise operator in any of
my videos or live streams I constantly
get people being like hey if you make a
tutorial on this cuz I have no idea how
these works so we're going to talk we're
gonna cover them okay and it's they're
going to be covered in such a way that
could probably be applicable to more
than just this series so
bitwise operators and binary kind of
stuff will happen next video so get
excited for that and then after that
we'll actually move on to the code so we
will be writing code next time as well
to test out this binary stuff alright
guys hope you enjoyed this video if you
did please hit the like button if you
really enjoyed it you can support me on
patreon the conference after channel
where you can pledge a certain amount
I'm a certain amount per month and for
that you of course get rewarded if you
pledge at least $5 per month you'll get
access to all dog and pure my source
code on github by a private repository
and whatnot and also one more per month
you get some pretty much some premium
top level support for myself week well
where we can just chat and and say stuff
to each other and you can ask me
questions and we can just have a nice
conversation that's always a good idea
if you want to have a conversation with
me that doesn't involve paying anything
then you want joint slack because if you
get a slide on the trailer comments on
out with your email address you will
gain access to my slack channel which is
the Turner dot slash calm okay this is a
nice little community of real-time
messaging okay so you'll be able to talk
with the hundred plus people that are
currently in that community which are
all of you guys all of you YouTube
viewers and whatnot and fans and and we
can I'm usually on there so we can have
a good chat usually and and it's just a
really good place to hang out while you
essentially write code and learn about
gap development so there we go that is
pretty much all I want to say so next
time binary bitwise operators let's get
that stuff was just absolutely nail that
stuff will have a lot of fun with it and
and it should be awesome so I'll see you
guys next time
goodbye